[Musique]
bonsoir c'est bien sûr une année très
triste pour le cinéma c'est pour ça que
j'ai décidé de venir en noir et en même
temps il faut se réjouir bien sûr il
faut se réjouir parce que dorénavant je
crois que c'est clair pour tout le monde
les producteurs n'ont plus le droit de
violer les actrices est par contre il ya
quelque chose qui n'est pas clair et
qu'il va falloir clarifier je pense
assez vite
c est ce que nous on a encore le droit
de coucher pour avoir les rôles parce
que c'est à dire que parce que si on ne
lui donnera alors il faudra
apprendre des textes
passer des castings et et on n'a pas le
temps franchement je le dis on a pas que
vous savez combien de temps il faut pour
faire ça là ça et c'est que ça bien sûr
c'est que ça imaginez les belles
imaginer penelope cruz
c'est beaucoup de temps d'entretien de
décoration c'est beaucoup de il faut on
va pas décider de ça ce soir bien sûr
mais il faudrait y penser